five bucks 5 bucks 5 bucks 5 bucks
that's a low-fat nonfat skim milk
whipped cream top sprinkles Starbucks
macchiato baby $5 is what those shoes
cost you but that scarf didn't cost more
than five bucks no the scarf is $5
there's no way you pay too much $5
that's a gallon of gas go look in your
couch I'm sure it's there I mean there's
not a lot that's five bucks that's like
a one finger manicure you probably get a
lot of stationery trying to find
anything that costs five bucks it's
actually true five dollars five dollars
probably get like a DVD that's from 20
years ago in that five dollar bin if
there even is no but it's plus tax that
that's more than five bucks five bucks
that's nothing a child is traffic to
every 30 seconds human slavery is the
fastest growing criminal industry in the
world human trafficking is a thirty two
billion dollar industry per year that is
more than what Chevron AT&T and GE made
last year combined there are over twenty
seven million people enslaved around the
world that's more than double the number
of Africans enslaved during the slave
trade over an estimated 2.5 million
people are in forced labor that's the
entire population of Toronto a majority
of trafficking victims are between 18
and 24 years of age that's young
that's like you that's like me whoever
you are whatever you do you have
something to offer your five dollars
will make a difference
five bucks can get you a front-row seat
to a great show if you're in Sacramento
LA the hood if you use it in the
Cordillera it does not matter come in or
log in on March 21st let's all join the
fight everyone is invited yes it's a
Wednesday night what else are you going
to do get off your bum what are you
doing
take action now because I'm not for sale
I'm not for sale not for sale you're not
for sale no one should be for sale now
later or ever
were you sad when he crossed our dreams
inside you're dying cuz you campaign he
will leave you
you're just